1 million d'astéroïdes qui
circulent entre Mars et Jupiter.
Bonsoir.
- Bonsoir. Oui. Peut-ê
plus. C'est ce qu'on arriv
compter.
les voir correctement. On est àà
peu près sûr de ce chiffre. On
arrive à voir les traitststs
grossiers. On sait qu'ils sont
là.mment?
C'est la petite planète?
- Ça peut aller de quelques plus
dizaines ou centaines deLes trèn
arrivait très bien les voir
parce qu'ils réfléchissent très
bien la lumière du soleil. On
arrive facilement les repérer. u
kilomètre et qu'on approche à
peu près le 140 m, ça devient
plus compliqué et cela ou
potentça devient très
dangereux parce qu'on peut se
laisser surprendre par ses
astéroïdes et il peut avoir une
trajectoire qui va croiser celle
de la terre.
- Quan
dinosaures avaient péri suite ïe
ou un météore réside?
- On parle de la même chose. Uïu
près 10 km minimum de diamètre.
Ce qui n'est pas très gros, mais
cela a suffi à faire cette
extinction des dinosaures.
Au Mexique dans le cratère.
Ça a causé la disparition on a
de plus en plus de preuves. En
2013 par exemple un plus petit
de diamètre a fait des dégâts
absolument incroyables. Il n'a
pas tué de gens, mais la blessée
des gens et celu
de 2013, cet ast
vraiment rentré dans
l'atmosphère terrestre il avait
causé
cette ville de la Russie. Les
risques là, il faut s'assurer de
r identifir identifir identifirs
de prendre les mesures
nécessaires pour agir pour
sonde permet d'offrir des
solutions.ement, DART,l'astéroïe
menace aucunement la terre mon
devoir si on est capable de les
faire changer de trajectoire.
- Oui. On essaie de faire
changer les trajectoire la lune
de cet astéroïde qui tourne
autour. C'est un astéroïde
double. On vise la petite lune
parce que c'est plus facil
d'amener de l'énergie pour
dévier légèrement sa trajectoire
et aussi on va être ca
de cette déviation.
C'est ce qu'on cherche à faire
avec cet astéroi
- Donc ce n'est pas que de la
fantaisie?
scientifiques évalue qu'un
intér
percute soit
l'équivalent de 1000 bombes
atomiques?omiques, oomiques, ooe
calme.
On a la chance d'avoir unehère a
terre de beaucoup de cesnts pos.
certaines conditions pour fairee
risques sont quand même l'est on
estime que c'est environ un à
deux sur plusieurs milliers
d'années que ça
dangereux. Il est homme quand
même sortir une quantité
colossale d'astéroïdes qui sont
très petits.
- Des petits cailloux.
- Des dizaines de tonnes par
année.
- Je les ai que 0,0 57 %
le risque de collision avec un
astéroïde.
- C'est le principe, 1/10 000
ans.
- On se protège.
- On ne sait pas exactement où
les plus dangereux, les petits
suffisamment larges, se cache
parce qu'on ne les voit pas
bien. Il faut se préparer. évite
dans un vaisseau comme dans le
film qui se sacrifie pour
l'humanité et il fonce dans
l'asté